abolishing it in a word
I think it's an anachronism it was
designed so that the masses were going
back to the 1800s actually 1700s would
not be able to directly influence the
outcome of the election there would be a
kind of intermediate body the Electoral
College that would be elected and they
would perhaps with deliberation make a
considered choice and thereby perhaps
endorse what the pop what regular
citizens choose but perhaps not the real
problem however is not the Electoral
College itself it's winner take all
so under the president rules in all but
Tuesdays the winner of a state even the
plurality winner and not necessarily the
majority winner if they're more than two
candidates wins all the electoral votes
of that state so in a state like
California with I believe now fifty
three representatives its electoral
votes and the number of its
representative fifty three plus the two
senatorial electoral votes that brings
it up to fifty five and that's about 10
percent of the entire electoral vote
which means California is very decisive
well in a sense not really because
California recently has been a
democratic state like New York Texas is
primarily a Republican state so these
states in effect don't swing votes
they're almost sure things one party or
the other but a state like Florida in
nineteen mm or a state like Ohio in 2008
we're critical to the election of Bush
in both years these were close elections
in each case so how they oh very much
determines the outcome and is it
necessarily the case that these large
states that can change the outcome in a
close election a representative of the
country as a whole
I think not moreover when it a call
means that you spend many more resources
even proportionally in these large well
their various names but they're
essentially toss-up states and even some
small toss-up states like New Hampshire
now is pretty much a state to go it has
gone either way
and basically ignore the states that is
kind of sure things California New York
Texas and I think elections presidential
elections would be much more exciting
and bring in everybody in all the states
if candidates had to seek out support
everywhere maybe roughly in proportion
to the size of the states but there
would be no toss-up states that would be
decisive everybody would be in that
sense decisive and what that does is
distort campaigns themselves candidates
spend the bulk of the time in these
toss-up states ignoring the rest of the
country the last president to visit all
50 states was Richard Nixon in 1960 in
his campaign against John Kennedy
pledged that he visited all 50 states
and despite injuring himself inside the
lighting is campaigned for ten days in
September of 1960 kept his pledge so he
spent basically the last 36 hours of his
campaign on planes to Hawaii and Alaska
still fulfill his pledge and then he
lost the election by a squeaker and most
people think of it spent a little more
time in Ohio or another key state you
would have won well in 1968 nixon
abandoned that strategy followed what it
was called the rose-garden strategy
basically stayed in the white house and
won the election so since then and no
candidate has visited all 50 states
whereas I think if we abolish electoral
college and votes counted the same
everywhere then we'd see much more
national
campaigns in all the states